[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight rapper Kanye West has
spent four days posting pro-trump
content on Twitter what does that mean
for America and humanity and life itself
we'll investigate just ahead
but first Fox's Bret Baier just
conducted a deeply revealing interview
with former FBI director Jim Comey
during that interview Comey tried to
claim that the Steele dossier the one he
hid information about from the president
was not central to their quest for a
FISA warrant against people affiliated
with the Trump campaign here's part of
it and called the dossier unverified
salacious why did you use that to define
a court to ask for surveillance for
Carter page not only use it but you led
with it a bulk of that fire application
deals with that dossier why yeah that's
not my recollection Bret and I don't
know that the FISA application has been
released my recollection was it was part
of a broader mosaic of facts that were
laid before the FISA judge to obtain a
FISA warrant it was a lot more than the
dossier in the FISA application my
recollection was there was a significant
amount of additional material about page
and why there was probable cause to
believe he was an agent of a foreign
power and the dossier was part of that
but was not all of it or a critical part
of it is my recollection I don't know
that it's been released hiding behind
government secrecy once again
congressman trey Gowdy represents South
Carolina he chairs the Oversight
Committee in the house representatives
and joins us tonight mr. chairman thanks
for coming on what did you you watching
a few what did you learn from it a
couple of things number one the page in
straw he would have fired immediately
which means the two ages that were
leading both the Clinton and Trump
investigations should have been canned
director Comey's recollection is flawed
if he does not remember telling Congress
that his agents told him they didn't
think flem was lying then he needs to
get his lawyers to go back and look at
the transcript we did not miss here
maybe he misspoke but that's in the
transcript and the double standard that
he's had for the last couple of weeks
still exists
you know Clinton can lie and she ought
to be president mccabe can lie and he's
still a stand-up guy but Trump boy if he
tells any lies at all then
Pietschmann is too good of a remedy for
him and that dangerous Martha Stewart
who went to prison for lying and he
brags about that in his book right
he doesn't remember a lot he doesn't
remember when he first heard about the
Steele dossier he does remember who told
him about the Steele dossier is that
plausible no because he knew that
Republicans paid for it even though
that's inaccurate so if he learned about
it in the fall of 2016 then it was
already known that the Democrats had
picked up on that work
so whoever briefed him why would you
just say the Republicans started it but
but not also include the Democrats
finished it so that that and and the the
part about it not being part of the FISA
application not a significant part then
Tucker why did you use it at all and
I've actually read the application and
he's just wrong it was an indispensable
part of the application period so how
can he claim otherwise I mean his first
reaction was I don't think that's been
made public in other words you can't
prove me wrong because you and the rest
of the civilians asking these questions
the American citizens here don't have
access to the relevant information but
as you just pointed out you do you've
seen it that's not true this forms a
central part of the request correct well
there are three parts of it this is one
of the parts they lead with it and if my
recollection is correct it occupied a
disproportionately large part of that
application so I go back and ask all
those who say it wasn't important then
why did you use it if you didn't need it
why did you use it and why did you lead
with it so let's get let's strip away
the politics and take Trump out of this
so we can see clearly at the core is the
allegation that Carter page the hapless
Carter page was acting as the former
director said tonight as an agent of a
foreign power is that a plausible claim
do you think any reasonable person
looking at the available evidence could
reach a conclusion that Carter page is a
Russian agent it'd be tough I think most
people that have any experience with
Carter page which would include the FBI
because they've interviewed him on a
number of occasions
um is would you'd be more likely to call
him a clown than a spy so what do you
make and I don't say that I don't say
that to be disparaging towards him I
mean I spend a lot of time with him in a
congressional committee room if anyone
needed his Fifth Amendment right to
counsel if anyone needed a lawyer while
he was talking to Congress it would have
been quarter-page I just don't I mean
he's not James Bond he's not Jason
Bourne he's it's sad actually
so if our top law enforcement official
can say with a straight face on live
television that Carter Paige is a
foreign spy and represents a threat to
American national security he's lying it
sounds like well I don't quarrel with
the FBI wanted to run out a lead I mean
I I'm probably biased or I am biased
towards law enforcement go ahead and run
out the lead the the challenge then
becomes when you are going to spy on an
American citizen it needs to be more
than a lead you need to have probable
cause and make all proper
representations to the court the other
thing I will tell you Tucker that I
learned tonight is Jim Comey has a
definition of the word leak that no one
else in house what he says is a leak is
what the rest of us call a felony
leaking is disclosing a confidential
conversation which is exactly what he
did he came off as much earlier in this
interview that